tyco and worldcom are some of the
companies profiled in William blacks new
book the best way to rob a bank is to
own one this is just over an hour
tonight to welcome William K black the
executive director of the Institute for
fraud prevention he is going to discuss
and sign his book the best way to rob a
bank is to own one the catastrophic
collapse of companies such as enron
worldcom M clone and tycho left angry
investors employees reporters and
government investigators demanding to
know how the CEOs deceived everyone into
believing their companies were
spectacularly successful when in fact
they were massively insolvent why did
the nation's top accounting firms give
such companies clean audit reports where
were the regulator's and whistleblowers
who should expose fraudulent CEOs before
they loot their companies for hundreds
of millions of dollars in this expert
insider's account of the Savings and
Loan debacle of the 1980s William black
lays bare the strategies that corrupt
CEOs and CFOs in collusion with those
who have regulatory oversight of their
industries used to defraud companies for
their personal gain recounting the
investigations he conducted as director
of litigation for the Federal Home Loan
Bank board black fully reveals how
Charles Keating and hundreds of other
SNL owners took advantage of a weak
regulatory environment to perpetuate
accounting fraud on a massive scale he
also authoritative lee links the SNL
crash to the business failures of the
early 2000s showing how ceos then and
now are using the same tactics to defeat
regulatory restraints and commit the
same types of destructive fraud black
uses the latest advances in criminology
and economics to develop a theory of why
control fraud looting a company for
personal profit tends to occur in waves
that make financial markets deeply
inefficient he also explains how to
prevent such waves throughout the book
black drives home the larger point that
control fraud is a major ongoing threat
in business that requires active
independent regulators to contain it his
book is a wake-up call for everyone who
believes that market forces alone will
keep companies and their owners honest
ladies and gentlemen please give a warm
welcome to miss
William black thank all of you Thank You
borders for staging this I'll start out
with why I wrote this book it was from
frustration in large part that we had
learned lessons from the savings and
loan crisis that helped produce the next
crisis instead of helping to prevent the
next crisis it's the old thing about you
don't get disasters from ignorance you
get disasters from the things that you
think you know which aren't true and we
thought we knew a number of things after
the Savings and Loan debacle that proved
to be completely untrue and because we
designed a regulatory system in light of
those false beliefs we've had the new
and even larger series of crises
involving control fraud control fraud is
simply a situation in which the person
controlling the organization whether it
is a corporation or whether it is a
nation uses their ability to control
that organization to loot it or to loot
customers in the modern situation it's
primarily been looting the creditors
looting the shareholders the final
absurdity of all this was driven home to
me in 2003 when the Justice Department
announced in a press release that
property crimes had fallen to an
all-time historical low except of course
unless fraud is a property crime in
which case property crimes had risen to
an all-time historical high and of
course they are property crimes and of
course the answer is we don't count them
nobody in the United States is
responsible for counting the major
frauds there are no reports on it and as
a result they essentially don't exist
for many political purposes and that is
an obscenity in the context of these
kinds of frauds because even on an
individual basis the large control for
cause greater financial losses than all
other forms of property crimes combined
in the nation right so the thing we're
not counting is bigger by far than
everything we do count and that means
that we tend to focus our resources and
absolutely the wrong areas and
absolutely the wrong way in control
fraud the CEO typically uses the firm as
a weapon but also as a victim
simultaneously to loot it to loot its
creditors and to loot its shareholders
and these control frauds cause these
amazingly large losses as I said much
greater than all of the forms a property
crime combined because they can do five
unique things the first thing they can
do is because the CEO hires and fires
all of the internal controls and
virtually all of the external controls
external controls are things like you're
outside auditor they can get rid of them
and they can hire the right kind of ones
so they don't simply defeat internal and
external controls that's actually the
wrong premise they suborn them and turn
them into their most valuable ally so a
clean opinion from a top-tier audit firm
is the best thing you can have going as
a control fraud and you've seen in the
Savings and Loan debacle and then again
recently that every single one of them
was able to get clean opinions from
top-tier audit firms typically for year
after year Keating's famous phrase was
his accountants were a profit center and
that was exactly true the second thing
that you can do is you can optimize the
firm for fraud because you are the CEO
and that largely means two things both
of which relate to the fact that if you
are a control fraud your weapon of
choice is accounting fraud how do you do
accounting fraud best first thing you do
is you invest in areas that
have no clear market value you don't run
these scams in something like wheat
where everybody knows the price per
bushel of the wheat you run it in things
in the savings and loan crisis like
massive office buildings massive unique
office buildings they have no clear
market value your home if you're
especially in a track is easy to figure
out the value within plus or minus five
percent you go to your neighbors open
house you find what your neighbors house
sold for you can make a very good
estimate of what your home is worth that
is not true of large office buildings
which have no clear comparables the
second thing that you do is you grow
extremely rapidly and so these largest
control frauds the reasons they cause
such massive losses is that they become
Ponzi schemes in a Ponzi scheme you grow
very rapidly and you pay off for a while
obviously the old debts with the new
debts but you're accumulating all the
time ever greater debts that will
eventually lead to catastrophic losses
and a CEO can do both of these things
the CEO can say we will now invest in
the following business lines exclusively
and so it's savings and loan after
Savings and Loan the new corrupt CEO
would come in they would stop doing home
lending and they immediately go towards
lending almost entirely for these large
commercial office building structures
and they would grow and they would grow
massively the control frauds in the
Savings and Loan industry averaged more
than fifty percent growth per annum
before the rear egg ulation set in I
don't know if that seems like a lot or a
little it's an extraordinary growth rate
that is completely unsustainable and
quickly leads to these kinds of Ponzi
disasters the third thing that they can
do and this is what converts it from
simply being a financial scandal to a
political scandal as well is when your
control fraud you can use the resources
of the
and the apparent legitimacy of the firm
that you control to change the external
environment so not within the firm but
classically of course you can change
regulation and so in n Ron's case we had
the famous situation that Ken Lay
bragged about creating the regulatory
black hole in energy derivatives and
because no one regulated it he was able
to use that in conjunction with other
members of the cartel to produce the
California energy crisis and very large
profits to Enron and obviously very
severe problems for the citizens of
California and Oregon and other Pacific
Northwest regions in the savings and
loan crisis this was even more dramatic
probably because it was one of the
striking features of the savings and
loan crisis that the greatest political
intervention took place for the two
worst control frauds in the nation
Vernon Savings and Loan known in the
regulatory ranks as vermin savings and
Lincoln Savings and Loan Charles
Keating's infamous Savings and Loan and
so speaker right and in the United
States sort of the answer to a trivia
question who is the most second most
powerful politically elected official in
America it's the Speaker of the House
well the speaker right went to bat for
Vernon savings and he went to bat for
Charles Keating's Lincoln Savings and of
course the Keating five the five US
senators so historically went to bat as
well for Lincoln Savings Vernon savings
ninety-six percent of its loans
defaulted right and if you thought
that's just because of the bad Texas
economy ninety-two percent of its loans
outside of Texas defaulted Lincoln
Savings was the most expensive financial
failure financial institution failure in
US history remains that at over three
billion dollars on a shop that was only
six billion dollars in total liabilities
so he was losing money at roughly 30
million dollars per working day charles
keating if you want to think about the
rate at which these people are able to
do it and so the extraordinary thing is
the absolute worst frauds were able to
get the greatest political intervention
and this political intervention was so
powerful that the legitimate members of
the industry the trade association
represented them reached what some of
its own members referred to as the
Faustian bargain in other words the
bargain with the devil in which they
would support each other to get their
common goals which was virtually no new
funds for the Federal Savings Loan
Insurance Corporation which we call
physic and what would called forbearance
provisions which were really provisions
designed to gut our ability to take
enforcement and of course the really sad
thing is that from a perspective of a
firm that's engaged in fraud a very
large political contribution is trivial
as I say Keating was losing 30 million
dollars per business day a
fifty-thousand-dollar contribution is
nothing in that situation a
fifty-thousand-dollar contribution even
today is a very important contribution
that will put you on a first-name basis
right so changing the external
environment is something unique to
control frauds and the answer is they
could all do it it's only audacity that
key or lack of audacity that keeps a
number of the frauds from doing so but
all of them could easily fund very large
contributions and many of them do and
collectively that could cause enormous
problems in our political system the
fourth thing that they can do uniquely
control frauds is to take money out of
the firm using seemingly legitimate
normal corporate mechanism and this
comes back to why control frauds use
accounting fraud as their weapon of
choice if you're an embezzler if you
stick your money in the till you have no
defense when you're caught right they
what do you say I meant to put it back I
was hoping to put it back in a while
that's the typical defense you get an
embezzlement case and typically it takes
the jury about 10 minutes to come back
with a guilty verdict in those
circumstances but if you use accounting
fraud you don't look like you're you
know okay as a business you look like
you are extraordinarily profitable if
you engage in accounting fraud and if
you grow rapidly you are mathematically
guaranteed it's not a matter of risk you
are mathematically guaranteed to report
that you are one of the most profitable
entities in the world and so Vernon
savings reported it was the most
profitable Savings and Loan in America
and Lincoln Savings in a later year
reported it was the most profitable
Savings and Loan in America and of
course Enron reported it was one of the
most profitable corporations in all the
world and worldcom and you can go
through the entire list in the period
when they're using the accounting fraud
and growing very rapidly they all report
extraordinary profits and that's how
important these frauds are it's not a
firm that makes itself you know that
slightly insolvent makes itself look
slightly profitable it's a firm like
Enron de that is insolvent to the tune
of eighty-five percent of its reported
assets that's able to picture itself as
if it's one of the most profitable firms
in the world to get a clean audit
opinion for years saying that and to
have investors treat it as if it's real
that's what allows you to cause tens of
billions of dollars of losses and it's
why even individual large control frauds
as I say cause greater losses than all
other forms of property crimes combined
and that is the extraordinary danger
that you can get people to believe the
things and so look at fast I'll the
infamous chief financial officer CFO of
Enron the man was technically
incompetent you may have read the book
or you may be familiar with it the
brightest folk guys in the room they're
nowhere near the brightest guys in the
room they're the most audacious people
in the room the least ethically
concerned people in the world and so
fast out for example kept a complex
equation for solving the value of
complex financial derivative in his
office on a whiteboard but he couldn't
do the equation it was the equivalent of
people who buy books and put them at the
back of their office that they've never
read and could never read and he was
named the best fuzz chief financial
officer in the nation by CFO magazine
the degree to which these frauds are
able to fool people is extraordinary and
if you are extraordinarily profitable as
a firm then what happens to the CEO in
the modern world stock options
appreciation of the stock bonuses perks
like you cannot believe that read like
you know the dying days of Rome type of
thing in terms of excess are all the
norm and all that none of those things
require you to ever put your hand in the
till which is why you can catch people
red-handed you can have for chief
financial officers testify that the CFO
ordered you to engage in this fraud and
they can be acquitted at least in
particular states they can be acquitted
if you're mr. scratching such and the
last thing that you can do that's
special to these frauds unique to them
is you can burnish the legitimacy of the
firm and your own legitimacy and status
using the firm's resources so it is
absolutely the norm for these control
frauds to start becoming great givers to
charity but with our money
not theirs right and that of course
helps them as well should there ever be
a criminal investigation now the
remarkable thing about the savings and
loan crisis I would suggest is twofold
given the hundreds of control frauds
that were operating one is we were
extraordinarily fortunate that the
savings Loan debacle was only a debacle
logically it was headed for catastrophic
reaches and as a result of in part the
actions of a number of people in the
audience here it was prevented from
becoming a complete catastrophe and it's
only up to its time the worst financial
scandal in US history of course been
passed by the current frauds the second
thing is and it comes from it perhaps
that was the problem perhaps if the
folks in this room and elsewhere in the
regulatory ranks had actually done what
the Economist claimed we did you would
have had a catastrophe which would have
given fraud a bad name and led to bigger
reforms perhaps consider the following
examples speaker right is holding the
Federal Savings Loan Insurance
Corporation bill that's going to give
money to physic hostage to extort favors
for don dixon of vermin savings and
similar control frauds in texas and he
demands of the chairman of the agency
heed gray that he fired Joe Selby the
top regulator in Texas saying that he's
a homosexual and running a ring of
homosexual lawyers you know preposterous
bizarre stuff any logical person in
Gray's position since physic was down to
five hundred million dollars in funds to
ensure an industry with it roughly a
trillion dollars in assets might well
have given in think what would have had
and if Ed gray had given in to that
extortion speaker was thinking what
speaker rights ethics investigation
would have been like in those
circumstances then think of the Keating
five icky ting five demanded of again
chairman gray that a Lincoln Savings
which had violated the direct investment
rule to the tune of over six hundred
million dollars be given immunity for
that violation that's what that meeting
was all about what if Gray had said yes
can you imagine what the Keating five
Senate investigation would have been
like when he then produced a three
billion dollar loss plus an immense
fraud targeted at widows who were left
uninsured to the tune of 22,000 of them
losing roughly three hundred million
dollars so in a bizarre way if Ed Gray
had not stood up to these people he
actually would have caused far more
catastrophic political changes in the
coming investigations in other words
they're most fortunate thing was that
they were dealing with that gray and not
a more normal regulator but then
considered the bizarreness of the
conventional economic wisdom which is
that the agency was quote captured by
the industry at regulated which is why
they were trying so higher hard to fire
ed gray and why they were trying so hard
to claim that people were homosexuals
and should be driven out of office and
why they were suing us for four hundred
million dollars in our individual
capacity and why they were writing memos
get black kill him dead I don't think
that squares well with regulatory
capture indeed I could think it's so far
the opposite that it is bizarre that the
conventional economic wisdom ended up
being complete fiction that has nothing
to do with the debacle
so time after time we had the bizarre as
feeling of knowing i'm a democrat for
example i'm in the room with gym right
and i'm trying to warn him off from
helping vermin savings I'm his only
friend in the room I'm his best friend
in the room and he's screaming and
cursing at me right and many people in
this room had experiences a bit similar
where we continue to do our job and
continue to try to give the best advice
we could to people who generally
speaking thought we were outrageous I
don't want to leave on that note because
you know I am someone who actually
believes we are in a great country and
we there were substantial exceptions to
this despite all the money despite the
fact that the the only thing that could
possibly cost someone like Henry be
Gonzales his safe seat in Congress was
going to bat against the interests of
Texas as it would have been portrayed by
the Texas savings and loans and despite
that and despite the fact that the
Democratic Party desperately didn't want
him to go forward with hearings on the
Lincoln Savings disaster because of the
role of the Keating five and four of
those five senators were Democrats
despite that fact he went forward and
people like Jim leach this wasn't simply
you know heroic Democrats Jim leach was
very supportive of that effort as well
and didn't turn it into some kind of
political circus aimed at Democrats but
aimed far more at the truth so I think
that in terms of time I would much
prefer to be talking with you instead of
at you I have largely not done the
anecdotes to say with a substance to
begin with and I'd like to turn it over
to questions at this point about
anything and everything you're
interested in the debacle
yes individuals like Mike mr. Gonzalez
and showing how much can be striped a
guy to your left that's right how much
could be structurally changed in the
reforms you'd like to see and how much
really are we all dependent upon a lot
of people sitting here by keeping the
same thing any worse
fracture and individuals are both
important and they're both reinforcing
in positive and in- directions so what
did we do I said we learned the wrong
lessons well one of the first things we
did was get rid of the Federal Home Loan
Bank board as an independent regulatory
agency because of course all executive
branch is hate independent regulatory
agencies and no one like Ed gray could
have arisen in an executive branch
agency and said no to all these things
and have rear egg y elated in the face
of opposition everywhere he looked so
the first institutional change we made
made it harder similarly we should have
learned institutionally what was one of
the you know the no brainers about the
savings and loan crisis Savings and Loan
examiners were paid considerably less
than banking examiners duh what do you
think is going to happen in those
circumstances so not only were we not
permitted to hire many examiner's
whatever limit they gave us we often
couldn't meet because we couldn't get
them or they would leave because they've
learned they could get twenty percent
more by going to the banking agencies
flash forward in time to then 90s and of
course to this decade and we decided the
SEC the Securities and Exchange
Commission shouldn't be allowed to pay
its people for comparable positions as
much as the banking regulatory agencies
and we decided it would be a really good
idea to save money by having far fewer
SEC reviewers and so when I was a young
lawyer and we were dealing with business
clients we could say you better do it
right because the SEC is vigorous in
stance porkin will come use the
enforcement director of the SEC at that
point and he will come in bass you so
let's do it clean and that gave us the
leverage to get with business clients
where they go yeah I guess we better in
that era most in fact the great bulk of
securities filings were actually
reviewed by somebody at the SEC
by the time of the crisis with Enron at
all it was down to closer to five
percent of securities filings were
actually reviewed at the SEC which meant
you could get away with it and in case
of Enron for example I think the last
time they looked at an Enron filing was
1988 I'm sorry 1998 all right and under
any logical system we should have
learned some lessons we learned in the
savings and loan crisis as well which is
you can't use your resources just spread
evenly you have to triage you have to
find the most dangerous situations which
clearly would have been the N Ron's of
the world and put more of your resources
there and look at them we didn't do that
as well we don't still I was talking
about this from one of my former
students working with the GAO who I will
allow to remain nameless unless I
causing troubles but we still at the GAO
have the responsibility to identify
high-risk activities but the SCC's
anti-fraud activities are still not
listed as a high-risk activity why
because if they foul up the money isn't
lost to Treasury it's lost to
shareholders and Gao only treats it as
high-risk as if the money is directly
lost by the shareholders so if EPA fails
in its mission and people die that's not
a high-risk activity we ought to change
those types of things institutionally to
come back to people ultimately people
are still critical and people are hard
to predict but you ought to care enough
to try to send the very best and that's
rare as opposed to the norm and it's
getting more ideological and at the
assistant secretary level and below and
the special assistance it's
extraordinarily ideological more so than
in my lifetime
and probably lifetime of others in this
room as well next sir wondering if you
could comment on the effectiveness of
the sarbanes-oxley Act in addressing
some of the concerns that you talk about
in your book sarbanes-oxley in my view
is not well directed towards solving the
problems of control fraud it does create
some benefits in the accounting realm
and we'll see how they pan out I mean we
obviously in a situation in which the
SEC chairman was removed because he was
viewed as too vigorous William Donaldson
but in a sense I'm being unfair and I
should come back to your question
William Donaldson was not removed he
resigned now the administration made it
clear that it wanted him to resign but
it made very clear that it wanted had
gray to resign and EDD gray refused to
go William Donaldson even though he is
at the end of his career independently
wealthy and has a reputation beyond you
know God's representative on earth in
these terms and doesn't have to worry
about it left and I haven't seen any
story that even asked the ethical
question should you resign in those
circumstances when you know the reason
you're being pushed out is to bring in
the leading opponent of reform and of
course previously Harvey pit was
selected for one reason only because he
was the leading opponent of accounting
reform in America right when we do those
kinds of things we produce disasters
again now sarbanes-oxley can't solve
that so it's the people at the top that
matter the most and of course they were
going to put in someone who was a very
distinguished gentleman but had no
knowledge of accounting that was the
Webster thing as well so three out of
four very bad choices have defeated I
think
anything that sarbanes-oxley was
designed to accomplish I note also that
the person they put in charge of the
Justice Department cleanup had been at
providian in a situation where he didn't
find huge fraud at his own company for
year after year that he was directly
responsible for overseeing those kinds
of things we we can do better I mean
there are lots of people out there just
as were brought in to clean up the
Savings and Loan industry and again are
often in the audience here could be used
people analogous to them to clean up the
more general securities industry yes
Jerry
right
particularly companies like I cow
cereal acquirers the way the youth
larger accounting to disguise my
weaknesses in our court
the question was I spend a great deal of
time talking about goodwill mergers in
the accounting aspects of that in the
book as it was used in the savings loan
crisis to produce fictional income and
net worth where their analogs in the
current crises including tai khoan
perhaps worldcom and others that did
substantial mergers a number of those
areas of accounting abuse were actually
cleaned up and I want to be in fairness
to them professional accountants as a
profession they have often been
constructive and I would say this is in
distinction to my profession which is
the law which has rarely been
constructive in terms of how we our
profession has been assisting these
frauds I don't have let's tell you it
drove me berserk to hear lawyer after
lawyer saying but of course i have to
give zealous advocacy to my client i
said yes your client is the Savings and
Loan the CEO is not your client he's
looting and destroying your client and
you're giving zealous help to him we're
trying to save your client so no the
accounting scandals were do scandals but
they used the same fundamental device
which is make sure you're invited doing
it in something that doesn't have a
clear market value and so Enron scandals
involve overwhelmingly selling business
operations that had no clear market
value and then Enron simply put its own
value and surprise it said they were
massively valuable when they were in
fact were essentially worthless in most
of these situations so the exact
mechanisms have change the fundamentals
of the accounting abuse are the same it
i'm sorry i arrived late and you may
have already addressed this but if you
got any thoughts on the pending GSC
legislation in terms of lessons learned
or not that you might care to comment
about yes we it comes back to the
institutional question and the people
question we set up a situation in which
the GSC the question is about the GSEs
and those are the government-sponsored
enterprises particularly I think in the
housing context was the nature of the
question and have we learned any lessons
there I that's another area where we
didn't learn the lessons and then we had
to learn them anew after scandals in
that situation we set up incredibly
powerful entities that I talked about
how you could shake the external
environment if you controlled the firm
well few people have ever been better
than Fannie and Freddie at shaping the
external environment an enormous number
of people probably a number of people in
this room have been on their payroll at
one time or another it doing something
Noble by the way not something terrible
because that's how you do it you do
initiatives for all kinds of things that
appeal to a wide range of people and
then you use complexity and that's what
we've seen in the government-sponsored
enterprises to a fare-thee-well I mean
they have made the accounting so complex
so arcane that it would take tremendous
resources to be able to look through to
what's really happening and they know
that the government's at a tremendous
comparative disadvantage in fighting
accounting battles first because so many
things are gray areas where they can
simply say our judgment is different
than yours but also because they can pay
the outside accountants and their
internal accountants far more than we
can pay in the governmental ranks and
that means that they're being smart
tactically and we have to get much
smarter
as a government in terms of how we set
up the regulation so that means actually
paying people and having a way to keep
expertise in the government and have the
you have you be an expert without being
an office head right we too often we the
only way to promotion is to make you
head of Peter Principle type thing where
you do something else as opposed to know
Wall Street pays people lots and lots of
money to do things that they have
expertise in and they keep doing it year
after year so we know how to do it we
know some of the restraints in terms of
congressional feeling about pay but it
is one of those classic pay me now or
pay me later situations and to give you
an idea of all this at one point that
our stock markets lost nine trillion
dollars in market capitalization okay a
trillion is a thousand billion so this
is not an Everett Dirksen situation that
a trillion here a trillion there sooner
or later you're talking about real money
a trillion is greater than the GDP of
all but 40 nations in the world nine
trillion was equivalent essentially to
the entire GDP of the United States of
America so I'd rather spend another 2.6
million and get some good accountants
and some good capital markets
specialists and keep them from being
hired away by Freddie and Fannie which
would be the next problem in many parts
of the country or in what people regard
is is a housing bubble and
financial institution says to giving Lee
increase the percentage of variable rate
loans or no interest loans that they're
making what are the lessons that you see
from the prior crisis that we are the
most concerned about today to get ahead
of potential fraud we're already behind
it of course because the bubble has been
many years in the making but yes the the
question is should we have learned
anything from past crises about how to
deal with bubbles and that is one of the
the great questions and the hardest
questions because bubbles are wonderful
things I mean afterwards people say
nasty things about bubbles but during
bubbles they're wonderful because we all
own homes and our homes are going up in
value you know and what would we think
if someone deliberately put the kibosh
on all this and caused housing values to
fall twenty percent would we hail that
person as a hero that's choice one I
don't think so and so you almost never
get someone deliberately breaking a
bubble by the way the exception to that
would be the savings and loan crisis
we're attacking the control frauds
because again a Ponzi scheme will
increase its lending in the face of a
bubble even as a glut occurs was
something in conjunction with the 86 tax
act that was deliberately done to help
break that bubble and it was enormously
successful at doing so so is someone
going to have the courage to do it at
the Fed level not a chance at the
regulatory level I think you can do it
by not calling what you're doing
fighting a bubble but instead calling it
dealing with prudent lending and so
there are far too many negative
amortization and similar loans as you've
talked about and we could limit them in
the regulatory ranks and we have at
times limited them in the past that at a
minimum will mean that a number of
savings and loans and banks will not get
into financial trouble or at least not
in nowhere near as deep of financial
trouble and
not with the agency's anymore but I
would urge them to do it but not call it
a fight against the bubble just do it on
the basis of and I dad in consumer
education if I were doing it but and
that one's serious actually i think that
there's a their enormous number of
homeowners who do not understand what
will happen in the event of the bubble
bursting in Texas where I now teach
hundreds of thousands of people lost
their home when you start losing your
home especially in America especially in
these periods when people are so heavily
in debt we are talking about homeless
situations for a significant number of
those people so I don't think that
people understand the risks they're
taking on these kinds of loans and
seriously i would encourage and a strong
initiative in the regulatory ranks on
those kinds of loans right now you know
six six months ago a year ago but now at
the best we can do there's
yes after successive waves of fraud
describe why we learned lessons
the question is after these successive
waves of fraud why have we still learned
the wrong lessons in large part because
the group that's created the
conventional wisdom is the group that
helped produce the Savings and Loan
disaster and that's primarily the
economist who said that deregulation was
a wonderful thing and that it would
bring all kinds of wonderful results and
it produced a disaster instead now you
have two choices in that circumstance
you can say I'm sorry I misled you I was
wrong I didn't understand economics very
well that'd be choice one that was taken
by none or you could say to the death
deregulation had nothing to do with it
fraud had nothing to do with it it's
only deposit insurance we have to get
rid of deposit insurance except that the
savings and loan crisis disproved that I
mean the theory with deposit insurance
from an economics perspective is this
because of you have deposit insurance as
a depositor you have no incentive to
care whether the bank or savings and
loan is healthy you're guaranteed so
take the highest rate and there is
substantial truth to that but savings
and loans sold stock nobody insured
those shareholders and those
shareholders were supposed to under
economic theory impose what's called
market discipline and there in no case
during the Savings and Loan debacle was
their effective market discipline from
shareholders against a control fraud not
a single case and there was none in the
current wave of frauds either in the
Savings and Loan debacle there were also
people called subordinated debt holders
the forgetting the fancy terms these are
people who have a substantial incentive
to make sure the savings alone is
healthy and they're supposed to have
expertise unusual expertise in being
able to evaluate that there is not a
single case where subordinated debt
holders exercised effective market
discipline in the Savings and Loan
debacle or in the current wave of frauds
and you can do the same thing on loan
participation because people who other
SNL's who bought loan participations
stood to lose money but loan
participants never exercised effective
market discipline the reason ultimately
is that all these things have been
saying challenged the efficient market
hypothesis which is the heart of modern
finance so if you're an economist it
wouldn't be just saying oops I'm sorry I
messed up personally it would be oops
I'm sorry and the fundamental thing I've
been telling you and basing all of my
policy recommendations on for 25 years
at the time now 35 years is either wrong
or it has very important exceptions
whenever there is substantial fraud and
worse I have no theory at all or
knowledge about fraud so I no longer
need to be paid five hundred dollars an
hour as a consultant because I actually
have no expertise that's useful in this
regard so there's no chance that
economists were going to take that
position in fairness George Akerlof
Nobel Prize winner in economics person
on the back of the book saying nice
things about the book said eggs the same
type of things that I did we work
together back in 1993 you would think if
a Nobel Prize winner in economics said
the conventional economic wisdom was
wrong people would at least cite him and
disagree with them if they disagreed
with them they simply ignore it
overwhelmingly in most economic accounts
of the event that's extraordinary to me
and sad about I teach microeconomics I
don't teach it that way but I'm still
sad to see the profession result in that
react in that fashion because of
embarrassment I think in large part yes
where it has investor in
the investment
turned down doing what happened and
having perfect twenty-twenty hindsight
what are some of the accounting red flag
that you should have looked for and he
think that's applicable to investing in
companies today you know what its recent
corporate frauds really good question
the question was given what we know now
if hindsight was actually accurate and
by the way I argue in the book it isn't
is one of the key things what would we
look for then during the savings alone
tobacco if we were investors to try to
spot the frauds and what should we look
for in the future and we have one of the
people in the room who looked for
savings and loans that would have the
characteristics that they were likely to
fail and we were actually very effective
in identifying those in advance by
looking for a couple of things first you
know every time there's a little fraud
and some typically you know elderly
woman is how the news accounts go who
bought something an investment where
they were promised a fifty percent
return someone goes through her plight
and then says but of course it was too
good to be true you can you know you can
have only limited sympathy for but why
don't we apply that to Enron right how
is it that Enron could invest in any
activity in the world and immediately do
better than everybody else why was that
a believable story in terms of finance
or economic theory or business theory it
isn't it is too good to be true they
were reporting vastly to greater profits
and so the first thing you would look
for is who are the folks reporting that
they are the 15 most profitable Savings
and Loan in America they have a
extraordinary high percentage a
probability of being frauds and you
would have avoided the top 15 the second
thing you would have looked for is the
pattern what are they investing in do
they diversify or have they pumped
everything into acquisition development
construction lending in the context of
the savings and loans and if they
done it in a market let's look at the
vacancy rate and you would have seen as
early as 1983 that Texas vacancy rates
had reached record levels and of course
that continues to grow because these
ponzi schemes continue to increase
lending and it's only when EDD grace
laps the growth restrictions on that
this fails to become an absolute
calamity take it forward in time as I
said what could possibly lead to Enron
being massively profitable the first
thing you look for is a difference
between cash what's happening on a cash
basis and what's happening on their
accounting basis and if you had looked
at Enron you would see they were
claiming enormous profits on an
accounting basis and the cash flow
suggested losses not even tiny profits
actual losses given what they would have
to carry in terms of their debt and such
so that would bend the most useful thing
and again looking are they investing in
areas where I am dependent entirely on
some accounting firm blessing numbers
that no one else can figure out if it is
pass it up right it's too great a risk
it might not be a fraud but from an
individual standpoint pass it up get a
diversified portfolio you know go
long-term push one justify damn cow
uninsured
pounds just on his say-so is
question is how did bush one justify
bailing out the uninsured portion of the
counts on his own authority how did that
happen the answer generally speaking is
he didn't the there was actual authority
under for the four real legislation in
1989 but if I could do an answer similar
to what's perhaps going to where you're
going most Danny wall decided not to
liquidate institutions even when it
would be cheaper to liquidate
institutions and in the liquidation you
don't pay off uninsured folks and Larry
White and his book says but it only
happened four or five times and he can
Danny wall chose to bailout institutions
even though if you the alleged cost
savings was coming from tax savings but
wait a minute were the federal
government any tax savings comes from us
and is really a cost not a savings so
those type of things occurred they
occurred in the last year of President
Reagan's presidency with the full
support of Vice President Bush but as
soon as January rolled around Danny wall
was told he was not permitted to do a
single new deal after the election and
the federal savings alone Insurance
Corporation was not permitted to be
conservator or receiver for any more
failures after I think late January of
1989 ceau Bush knew how bad and how out
of control things were it was useful to
get past the election and Danny wall has
been quite candid in saying he was a
good soldier who his phrase is in his
testimony to Congress everyone knew I
was talking in code is his raise so when
he said we don't really need federal
funds that was code for we really need
federal funds
so it's not a lie because everybody knew
he was lying if you follow me why why
we're their non-existent kind of day get
their money back after the savings alone
and fail how did depositors get their
money back they got their money's back
from us as taxpayers there was a and
since it wasn't sure well no
overwhelmingly deposits were insured if
you look it would be on the average of
about ninety nine point two percent of
all deposits in a failed SNL were in
fact insured so there isn't much
uninsured money in the typical savings
and loan particularly in that era
because people knew that the insurance
fund was insolvent and you'd be nuts to
keep very much money at an uninsured
account so banks big banks are different
they have lots of uninsured money you
know they have accounts for 20 million
dollars savings and loans rarely had
that kind of thing hundred thousand
hundred thousand per institutions so you
could have there were roughly 3,000
institutions you could have many
millions of dollars fully insured in
savings and loans so I think it's a
little different than you say but the
general point that Bush knew that the
bank board was up to very strange things
got past the election and then
immediately shut it down is a true point
in something that I mentioned the book
yes seem to remember that the the SNL
issues never became a shouting issue in
any of the presidential elections I
assumed that that was no was trying to
cause a run or anything like that what
would be your explanation assuming that
my memories correct yeah your your
memory is absolutely right that the
Savings and Loan debacle never became a
major political issue in the
presidential campaigns and the reason it
didn't is the people in glass houses
problem and the further reason though
and this is what drove me so crazy as a
Democrat sitting in Speaker I
office is if you go back in time this is
when we meet with him it's februari 10th
1987 there had been a series of scandals
in the Reagan administration and there
was a major problem that the Democrats
were planning to use the sleeves factor
as it was then known in the next
presidential election and it's at that
juncture that speaker right intervenes
on behalf of us whole series of Texas
control frauds and then tries to fire
the top regulator the most prestigious
regulator in America at the behest of
the frauds and then went on from there
it was an amazing thing and he just
handed away the issue and so in the next
race the Democratic candidate mentioned
the savings loan crisis one night the
Republicans shot back was speaker right
within hours and that was never heard
from again because of course right
didn't want that issue raised because he
was now in ethics trouble and it was
eventually cost him his job along with
some you know some other things as well
yes I'm glad you amended your remark all
economists to most economist certainly
there are non mainstream not
neoclassical economists who would share
your views so we could turn the question
around and as
they get attention in the media why
don't they get government leaders here
that's one question but I had another
one haven't we set up and weren't you
implying that we've set up an incentive
scheme inviting fraud by setting up
governance structures where the
executives in the corporation get lots
of money when the stock price goes up
yes okay so two questions or one's a
statement / question that there are many
economists who are non mainstream who
might well be supportive of the
positions i've been saying today and it
there are is quite correct and why don't
they get heard as much they don't get
hurt as much for the usual reasons the
folks who control the journals will not
approve articles under peer review that
say things like this is a part of the
answer but other people won't fund them
as well and most research is driven by
funding so that's part of it but more
often it simply you're taught as a young
economist a certain thing and that you
know you you believe those things it
shapes your worldview the second
question was am I suggesting that we've
set up in the governance structure of
corporations an incentive system which
is economic thought is how we approach
these topics that encourages control
fraud yes absolutely and in and by the
way there are economic studies showing
just this that fraud is more common when
you have larger stock options and so and
this is critical because these stock
options were sold on the basis that they
would perfectly align the interests of
shareholders and the CEO and so the CEO
would be a faithful agent on behalf of
the shareholders which is great but it's
the old economics joke about assuming
the can opener because the CEO decides
how the stock options will be structured
and we know empirically how they
structure them they structure them short
term which is the easiest
to manipulate as opposed to long-term
and when the options go what's called
out of the money they restructure the
option so it comes back in the money so
options are supposed to be if you do
very well for the corporation you too
will gain and if you do poorly for the
corporation you will lose and of course
they've changed it to whether or not the
corporation does well you the CEO will
do very well and that creates its scent
of structures to mismanage and even loot
the corporation and that's what control
fraud is about yes I argue explicitly
that instead of being a protection it's
one of the more dangerous things that
we've done so co will call author the
next one questions
can I eat up one more time on economist
as you know it well you ain't got one
behind one on Main Street I'm doing Dita
Von I name's Troy out perhaps you push
me into this already as you know
George
for left to the effort by heating
to use against
do you ever see the profession
having some finding on this kind of
activity yes the question is Alan
Greenspan and George Benson were very
active on behalf of Lincoln Savings in
arguing against tree regulation and have
they ever done anything saying Mia culpa
in essence not only have they never done
anything like Mia culpa there were they
paid no price at all for being as wrong
as you possibly could so Alan Greenspan
wrote a letter saying that Lincoln
Savings pose quote no foreseeable risk
unquote to the Federal Savings Loan
Insurance Corporation and he did this on
supposedly in the basis of their
financial statements well i did a
contemporaneous memorandum I was a kid
right presumptively his financial
analytical abilities are a little beyond
mine mine said the opposite on the basis
of the available information key
Greenspan was also used people don't
know this to recruit the Keating five
all right he came in person to recruit
the Keating five and that's I think I'm
the first person to point that out
George Benson did the actual substantive
work because you know Greenspan's a big
man so Benson did a study I mentioned
direct investments earlier and he
praised 34 institutions that had done a
number of direct investments flash
forward two and a half years every
single one of them failed and what is
George Benson right to this day there
was no basis for restricting direct
investments they were wonderful
investments well you know there's no
consequence he got and you know what
happened Alan Greenspan after what he
wrote George Benson got an endowed chair
at Emory and DF fishell who was a
professor who wrote that Lincoln Savings
posed no risk to the Federal Savings
Loan Insurance Corporation he became
Dean of the University of Chicago Law
School I mean
I didn't screw up enough you know I if
I'd managed to get it all wrong my
career path would have been so much
better it's hard to believe the thing
I'm sure I'll screw up in the future and
perhaps good things are in time one more
so it's an important one it's the last
we're leaving on that note Oh question
don't we want to wonder if these
mainstream Economist's are serving some
purpose
charge other than four
temptations to fraud
so the question is are should we be
considering what if anything the
mainstream economist who present these
views and reward people who get things
wrong are serving you know what is their
function why do they can in economic
theory people only get returns if
they're providing value and such a what
value are they providing and that is you
know and the thrust of your question I
fear is correct they they pose value for
the policies that the political folks
believe in so there was a really
striking one in 1983 there was something
called the agenda for reform in which
the bank board brought together a whole
series of condiments including Nobel
Prize winner Fischer black and such and
it was all done by economists the
supervisors the poor pitiful supervisors
were listed underneath the secretaries
and this was not in alphabetical order
right and they write an extraordinary
thing which they didn't tell the public
much they said deregulation in these
circumstances is desperately dangerous
it may cause very large losses but
that's not the danger they were worried
about the danger they was worried about
is those very large large losses might
lead to re-regulate and that was the
danger that needed to be stopped and
they are explicit about it indeed they
put that quotation on the cover of the
volume to emphasize that was the real
danger not that we would have losses but
that we would learn from the losses and
engage in rear egg y elation so thank
you again mores thank you very much
all we will give us a moment to set up
William blackheads the University of
Texas at Austin anti-fraud Institute the
best way to rob a bank is to own one is
published by university of texas press
more information at you texas press com